paris match risque quinze mille euros
damende pour sa une sur sa une donc on
envoie piotr pawlinski l'activiste russe
à l'origine de ce qu'on appelle
désormais la sphère grippaux allongée
sur le sol menotté
derrière lui presque un peu extérieur à
la scène alexandra de taddeo est debout
c'était en milieu d'après midi samedi
dernier à boulogne les journalistes de
paris match et étaient présents ils ont
filmé et photographié la scène est
choisi de mettre en une un des clichés
sur à la une de l'hebdomadaire qui est
paru hier
ce matin l'avocat pénaliste eric
dupond-moretti n'était pas très content
écoutez vous avez vu la une de paris
match et maître eric dupond moretti
scandaleuse pourquoi parce que la loi
guigou
1 entrée en vigueur en juin 2000
interdit de photographier un homme
menotté madame qui a mis les menottes à
monsieur pas plein ce qui ce n'est pas
paris match mais madame moi j étais pas
j'en sais rien je sais pas comment ça
s'est passé je ne sais pas ce qui a été
dit ce que je dis c'est que la police a
le droit de mettre des menottes mais que
la presse n'a pas le droit de publier
des photos d'un homme menotté c'est la
loi alors effectivement l'article 35 de
la loi sur la liberté de la presse de
1881 dit que la diffusion par quelque
moyen que ce soit et quel qu'en soit le
support de l'image d'une personne
identifiée ou identifiable mis en cause
à l'occasion d'une procédure pénale mais
n'ayant pas fait l'objet d'un jugement
1 soit que cette personne porte des
menottes ou entraves et puni je vous lis
l'essentiel et punis de quinze mille
euros damende est ce qu'elle vous
dérange
nicolas domenach c'était une écoute et
ça me ça me dérange d'abord
effectivement elle contrevient à la loi
mais surtout je trouve que ça participe
comme un article du monde de ce jour
au fond à une érotisation d'un
personnage qui pour moi est une crapule
un délateur dire dans le monde on en
fait un artiste russe
on le présente comme performeur qui
remet ccc un cafard c'est un cafard 2.0
je veux dire et comment pourquoi le
mettre en scène de manière sublime et
c'est pareil c'est d'une certaine façon
vous pouvez être sûr qu en présentant
cette photo de match on en fait une
personnalité je suis dire que on en fait
vraiment un bandit suprême tout ça me
dérange prof
on dément je trouve qu'on est on marche
sur la tête quoi qu'il ya un moment où
ça où il faut dire que ça c'est ce qui
m'a choqué c'est que j'ai vu des
réactions aussi sur les réseaux sociaux
on accuse le flic vous rendez compte un
homme à terre il est là violemment quel
besoin avait-il de le jeter par terre
alors que si j'ai bien lu c'est ce
personnage qui s'était mis par terre lui
même qui s'était assis et il ya quand
même la mise en scène j'ai trouvé de la
violence d'un policier et on adore ça en
ce moment
mettre en scène ce dôme violence des
policiers donc je trouve que c'est
malgré tout les pois ya la fille
ravissante derrière on dirait une
publicité pour un feuilleton mais c'est
ce que dit la journaliste d'europe 1 ce
matin sonia mabrouk elle dit en fait
parfois c'est bien que les journalistes
soient là parce que comme ça ils vont
ils peuvent voir s'il ya eu une base
journaliste autre chose à faire que ce
type de publicité c'est accrocheur c'est
une racoleuse et je suis pas d'accord le
journal mieux que ça adrien matou votre
avis les bavures il y en a vraiment été
très fâcheuse mais là je pense qu'il ya
plus de bavure et qu'il risquait pas y
en avoir il ya besoin de mettre des
menottes
peut-être pas mais en fait la vraie
question justement qui qui qui est
contenu dans la vôtre c'est est-ce que
pas le vent ce qui est était d'accord
avec cette mise en scène est ce que
c'est lui parce que c'est une vraie
possibilité c'est quelqu'un qui
cherchait absolument l'attention
médiatique etc
donc est-ce que c'est lui qui a convoqué
la presse voilà parce que si
effectivement s'il n'a pas convoqué la
presse ce n'est peut-être pas nécessaire
de mettre les menottes mais moi je pense
qu'il n'est pas mécontent du tout de
cette une bon que dire sinon que c'est
du cynisme en fait parce que c'est
quelque chose d'assez vieux dans la
presse people c'est à dire que ils
savent que mes contreviennent à la loi
en publiant cette une
mais ils savent que l'amande qui vont
payer d'un est inférieur aux ventes
qu'ils vont faire avec 1 10 euro pareil
donc c'est finalement c'est assez
cynique quoi c'est que au fond on a
l'impression d'assister à une série de
netflix chat avec des épisodes chacun
des rebondissements des possibilités des
tiroirs qui vont s'ouvrir
est ce que est ce que ce peintre au
couteau est pas un espion russe
retourner enfin ce qui n'a pas été
retourné par le kg mais enfin ex-kgb etc
mais c'est pas une série il ya des
hommes il ya des femmes
des enfants qui lui qui en prennent
plein la tronche dire qu'ils vont être
victimes de tout ça veut dire c'est pas
du cinéma
c'est un truc ça touche des
personnalités réelles veux dire c'est
peut-être un délateur c'est pas un
lanceur d alerte veut dire il faut
arrêter ces confusions là c'est quelque
chose lors d'un autre ordre derrière il
ya des vies qui sont en jeu et moi je
trouve ça absolument scandaleux de le
présenter comme sa part le gouverneur la
pudeur c'est c'est très français ce que
vous préféreriez un système à
l'américaine s'est déroulé le premier
amendement de la constitution américaine
nuit il permet tout de ce point de vue
là je suis assez proche
effectivement de la société
nord-américaine et
j'approuve le plus tôt le premier
amendement je pense par exemple j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de le dire ici que
tout ce qui concerne je dirais le les
limites à la liberté d'expression
doivent avant tout être liés je dirais à
l'état de la société aux coutumes aux
traditions je dirai à la politesse
beaucoup plus qu'au droit pénal
bon cela dit pour ce qui est de ceux de
ce monsieur
effectivement je partage votre opinion
sur le fait que c'est sans doute un
pseudo artistes cela dit le fait qu'on
qu on veuille le faire passer pour un
martyr parce qu'on l'a menotté alors que
lui même a fait effectivement des des
commandes hier des performances comme on
dit en ce clou temps une partie intime
de sa personne sur la place rouge
je pense qu'il a moins souffert
lorsqu'il a été arrêté que lorsque il a
fait cette performance là cela dit il ya
un point qui moi me paraît important je
n'ai pas regardé pendant des heures les
réseaux sociaux mais je les ai quand
même un tout petit peu scruter et ce qui
m'a beaucoup frappé c'est que bien sûr
tout le monde s'accorde à dire que le
fait de diffuser de manière publique une
vidéo
relevant de l'intimité privé c'est
déloyal c'est parfaitement déloyal
encore faut-il évidemment quand même
rappeler que c'est quand même le fait de
tourner cette vidéo qui est avant tout
déshonorant mais ce qui me paraît
essentiel c'est que quelle a été la
réaction de beaucoup d'internautes
ils ont été me semble-t-il choqué du
fait qu'il y avait une défense à
l'unisson par on va dire entre
guillemets la classe politico médiatique
je dirais de de grimaud et il me semble
que il y à un risque réel qu'il y ait de
plus en plus une distorsion
à partir de ces questions-là sur les
questions de moeurs de moralité privée
et c'est une distorsion entre le commun
des mortels et l'élite où les élites
c'est à dire que lorsqu'on a la sphère
veinstein lorsque l'on a la ferme à 19
qu'on s'aperçoit que des intellectuels
avaient approuvé des écrits ouvertement
pédophiles lorsqu'on s'aperçoit
qu'effectivement il y a une vie dissolue
de la part de personnes non pas qu'ils
sont des pipoles que l'opinion publique
le tolère mais deux personnes qui ont en
charge le bien commun qui ont en charge
le destin du pays est bien là je crois
qu'il ya un vrai risque
je dirais même s'il ya incontestablement
une atteinte à la vie privée qu'il ya un
vrai risque d'un sentiment je dirais de
2,2 de commentaires de d'appartenir à
deux mondes différents donc que
évidemment on n'approuve pas la
publication c'est une chose de cette
vidéo que par ailleurs je dirais on
excuse totalement une personne pour au
final je dirais rendre entièrement
responsable celui qui l'a rendu public
et non pas celui qui est responsable de
l'acte c'est à dire l'adultère au départ
j'avais dit que la yaris ne peux pas
vous dire ça c'est pas des zones ronde
c'est sa vie privée ça ne vous regarde
pas ça ne me regarde pas il fait ce
qu'il veut de ceux de son sexe de sa de
son de son rapport à sa famille de son
rapport il ya des familles très heureuse
avec des avec des infidélités je salue
on s'en fout dire vivant jusqu'à 10
il peut pas instrumentaliser sa famille
comme argument électoral et ensuite
effectivement avance à distance ce sujet
et on sait bien c'est l'habitude qui
devient coupable je trouve ça incroyable
non mais la victime attendait la victime
il est victime y est de sujets quand il
n'y a pas d'avis que jamais rien dit que
son terminal de lille il ya deux sujets
il ya il est totalement victime
totalement victimes des réseaux sociaux
de ce qui s'est passé etc
mais je veux dire que il ya aussi une
question alors on n'ose plus prononcé le
mot de morale un peu populaire ou au
plein sa femme ses enfants où il était
comme un porte-parole du gouvernement ou
la presse s'est étalée sur la façon dont
il se comporte et où il a été tellement
maladroit parce que on fait ce qu'on
veut d'accord dans sa vie privée
quand on est parole porte-parole d'un
gouvernement qu'on utilise les réseaux
sociaux peut danser mais c'est de la
bêtise voire plus le fait que jean
franchement ça va mais non mais il ya
quand même s'il a quand même une femme
qui est horriblement malheureuse qui
déshonorent vh suis désolé on peut pas
complètement passée sa balle et ses
mains c'est pas un problème est là et
les gens le jeu reprend la face à
d'ailleurs regardez les gens ne lui
reproche pas eu tout ça c'est pas du
tout va bien maintenant mais je compte
le pido je suis d'accord non l'opinion
publique n'est pas devenu puritaine mais
il est plus été tuées dans le 6 9 de
part la morale
le problème c'est qu'il ne faudrait pas
sous prétexté un coupable
vraisemblablement votre russe l'a eu
coupable de déloyauté et d'avoir diffusé
une choses intimes shops par ailleurs il
n'ya pas une faute originelle d'un
célèbre et je crois qu'il faut maintenir
les deux éléments sans courant rien à
tous les autres concurrents je vais voir
rien maîtriser les ménages
je pense qu'il ya pas de faute mais qui
a une erreur d' imprudence voilà pour
essayer pas de pour moi c'est pas une
filière et peut-être je vous lis ont
commencé les encore prudents et nous pas
bien plus porteuse du vol nous dit sur
figaro life in en garde si griveaux
n'avait pas fait la vidéo il n'y aurait
pas eu de diffusion et babine onudi
paris match on fera peut-être la loi
mais il ya une demande pour ce type de
ses portes faute sous que du marché
merci infiniment
de nous avoir si on vous souhaite à tous
un excellent week-end et on vous
retrouve lundi
[Musique]